comedians like Bert ker Kevin Hart and
Dave Chappelle each made over $20
million last year these are some of the
craziest ways Comics spend their money
starting off with Lou CK who once used
all the money from a single soldout show
at Madison Square Garden to buy himself
a grand Banks 341 yacht worth an average
of
$250,000 Dave Chappelle's car collection
is next valued at 713k including a slick
Rolls-Royce worth half a million dollars
speaking of Car Guys Tom sagora made
waves on the ru garbage podcast when it
was revealed he spent SP 50k on his
birthday dinner that's more than I made
last year Tim Dylan's real estate Empire
is no fake business his homes in Austin
LA and The Hamptons total over $12.6
million ber kusher loves the road life
and just invested in purchasing his own
souped up tourbus Kevin Hart's watch
collection includes a $520,000 Rolex
Daytona rainbow and a rare Nautilus rep
that cost $1.1 million it seems like
comedians are making more money than
ever nowadays for example